[Music]
in 1911 a physicist performed an
experiment that led him to the discovery
of the nucleus
Ernest Rutherford's observation of this
tiny collection of particles opened the
door to momentous scientific
breakthroughs including but not limited
to the field of nuclear power I'm rich
Burnett for wandrium and in this episode
of perspectives four experts delve into
the fascinating world of nuclear
reactions and the benefits and risks of
nuclear power we start now with a quick
look at nuclear energy consumption and
then we dive deep into the subatomic
realm where the real magic happens
[Music]
currently nuclear fission provides about
11 percent of the world's electricity
which is just under six percent of the
world's total energy consumption this is
about 300 gigawatts from 450 nuclear
reactors worldwide the global
distribution of nuclear power is more
limited than other energy sources you
know anyone can burn coal but you have
to have a high level of technological
infrastructure to build and maintain a
nuclear reactor and currently only 31
countries have that ability
the U.S is the largest user of nuclear
power accounting for about a third of it
and this provides 20 percent of all U.S
electricity other countries that are
large users of nuclear power France
Russia Korea and China and actually for
nine countries mostly in Europe led by
France nuclear power provides 40 percent
or more of their country's electricity
so nuclear power provides an important
but modest contribution to world energy
supplies at least compared to the fossil
fuels
let's take a look at what we think is
going on at a subatomic level within the
generation of nuclear energy during
fission and fusion a small amount of
mass is converted into binding energy
some of which is released as radiation
that we can use as a source of heat
let me start by going back to the
example of that helium atom the nucleus
of most helium atoms contains as I said
two protons and two neutrons and we know
the masses of individual protons and
neutrons a proton is
1.00728 atomic mass units a neutron is
1.00866 atomic mass units slightly
larger so if you added two protons and
two neutrons together you would get are
you adding this up
4.0319 atomic mass units I'm sorry for
all the decimal places but I need to
include them to make a point here okay
two protons two neutrons
4.0319 atomic mass units however if you
look at the nucleus of a helium atom
that's not what you get sure enough you
have two protons and you have two
neutrons but the mass is less it's now
4.0015 atomic mass units this is less
than the mass of the separate protons
and neutrons and this is very strange
this is one case where the hole is
actually less than the sum of the parts
the difference between the two
0.0304 atomic mass units this is a
little less than one percent so so this
is strange you take four particles you
put them together and you suddenly lose
one percent of their Mass where did that
missing Mass go well it went into the
energy needed to bind the particles
together and you can calculate exactly
how much energy that is after all energy
is conserved and we know that Einstein's
equation E equals m c squared will tell
us how much energy we get from the mass
the missing Mass turns out to be about 5
times 10 to the minus 29th kilograms
that's incredibly small but when we
multiply it times the speed of light
squared which is 3 times 10 to the
eighth meters per second squared that's
a very big number we now get four and a
half times ten to the minus 12 joules
that's for each helium atom so joining
the neutrons and the protons to make the
helium nucleus converts the mass into
energy a lot of energy one gram of
helium made from Fusion that's about the
weight of an almond generates the same
amount of energy as you get from burning
23 million grams of coal 23 tons of coal
from something the size of an almond a
nuclear power plant is similar to a
coal-fired plant
in the sense that both use closed-loop
steam Cycles to spin turbines the big
difference is simply that the source of
energy used to produce the steam is
different it's chemical energy for a
coal-fired plant nuclear fission for a
nuclear plant
nuclear fission the splitting of atomic
nuclei depends on the unique behavior of
certain heavy elements called fissile
materials which are used as nuclear fuel
by the way the word fissile means easily
split and so a fissile material is one
that's capable of sustaining The Chain
Reaction associated with nuclear fission
the most common fissile material is
uranium-235
when the nucleus of a u-235 atom is
struck by a neutron it breaks apart
releases energy and emits a few free
neutrons
if a sufficient quantity of this
material is assembled in one place the
neutrons emitted by the fission of one
nucleus will encounter adjacent nuclei
causing them to split release energy and
emit more neutrons as this process
continues progressively more free
neutrons cause the fission of
progressively more nuclei and the result
is a nuclear Chain Reaction
self-sustaining fission if this chain
reaction is controlled we have a very
potent source of energy if it's
uncontrolled we have a nuclear explosion
but how does this reaction get started
in the first place well uranium-235
experiences a small amount of
spontaneous fission a natural form of
radioactive decay that releases a few
neutrons so we really only need to
assemble a critical mass of uranium-235
and this naturally mission of neutrons
will set the nuclear chain reaction in
motion
nuclear fuel is prepared for use in a
reactor by molding uranium into small
pellets which are then sealed inside
metal tubes to create fuel rods
the tubes are made of zirconium alloy
used because of its corrosion resistance
and low Neutron absorption
the purpose of the tube is to contain
the uranium pellets so fragments can't
break away and contaminate the reactor
coolant
the fuel rods are assembled into bundles
of about 200 each like this and about
150 such bundles are then combined to
form the reactor core
these holes in each bundle allow for the
insertion of control rods cylindrical
bars made of boron carbide a material
that's particularly effective at
absorbing neutrons when the control rods
are inserted into a fuel bundle they
absorb enough free neutrons to prevent
the fission reaction from sustaining
itself thus they keep the nuclear
reaction from getting out of control
when they're withdrawn they allow the
reaction to proceed how do we turn heat
into electricity well we have to obey
the three laws of thermodynamics the
three laws of thermodynamics are you
can't win you can't break even and you
can't quit or
what it really means is you can't win
energy is conserved you can't break even
which says that entropy increases or the
amount of useful energy decreases and
you can't quit so what do we do we use
the heat to boil water to turn a turbine
to spin a generator
and
we need a cold sink to dump the waste
heat into that cold sink can be a river
a lake or an ocean or we can use a
cooling tower cooling towers get rid of
some of that waste Heat by evaporating a
lot of water and that peculiar shape of
cooling towers that you see on the
skyline is there to maximize the airflow
and the thermodynamic efficiency is
about one-third and so that means that
two-thirds of the energy has to be
dumped into rivers lakes or oceans or up
the cooling tower and that's due to the
limitations of thermodynamics we use the
same process for coal natural gas and
nuclear power to turn heat into
electricity
what kind of reactors do we use today we
use light water reactors so that's
regular hydrogen not deuterium the water
is both the moderator and the coolant
and these were originally developed for
the U.S Navy under the guidance of Hyman
rickover
there are two general types of light
water reactors there's a pressurized
water reactor where the water is under
high pressure so it doesn't boil higher
pressure means a higher boiling point
and so the primary cooling water then
has to transfer its heat to a secondary
water system the secondary water system
is allowed to boil and turn a turbine
the second kind of light Water Reactor
is the Boiling Water Reactor which is
just what it sounds like the primary
water is allowed to boil and we use the
steam from the primary water system to
turn the turbine and so it doesn't need
a secondary water system
then there's the pressurized heavy Water
Reactor the can-do plant in Canada so it
uses a heavy water moderator so that's
deuterium oxide and a heavy water
primary coolant until it can use
unenriched uranium and then the heavy
water transfers its heat to a light
water secondary system which then boils
and turns the turbine
there's also a water cooled graphite
moderated reactor and so that's similar
to fermi's original reactor so graphite
moderated but now it's water cooled it
can also run a natural uranium so this
is the Chernobyl type reactor and it's
built for power and for producing bomb
grade plutonium
the pressurized water reactor is the
most common reactor in use today uses
pressurized water at 150 atmospheres and
about 300 degrees Centigrade which is
about 600 fahrenheit as the coolant and
the moderator in the reactor vessel it's
a closed loop we don't let that water
Escape
there's a reactor pressure vessel which
is about 40 feet high it's about 15 feet
in diameter and it's made of eight inch
thick Steel
the primary water system then transfers
it to a secondary water loop in
something called a steam generator and
then it has a containment building with
concrete and steel to contain everything
inside of it
the pressurized water reactor then the
non-nuclear part the steam from the
secondary water system turns to turbine
the turbine turns the generator there's
a condenser that condenses the steam to
make the low pressure side of the
turbine and we need a cooling source for
that condenser which as we said can be
an ocean a lake a river or a cooling
tower
now it's important to recognize that
from a macro perspective the advantages
of nuclear power are considerable
nuclear plants can operate at Max
Capacity for extended periods of time so
they're very effective at meeting base
load
although nuclear fuel is a non-renewable
resource there's enough of it in the
Earth's crust to last for centuries more
importantly properly contain nuclear
fission produces minimal air pollution
and no CO2
in the first decade of the 21st century
a growing appreciation for these
advantages coupled with post-9 11
concerns about our dependence on energy
sources from unstable regions of the
world led to a Resurgence in enthusiasm
for nuclear power both in the U.S and
abroad many new power plant construction
projects were initiated and there was
talk of a nuclear Renaissance and of
nuclear power as a major component of a
new environmentally friendly power
generation system
and then came the 2011 Fukushima power
plant disaster throwing the nuclear
industry back on its heels once again
the Fukushima incident was triggered by
a magnitude 9.0 earthquake off the coast
of Japan
initially the plant Safety Systems
worked exactly as they were supposed to
in all three operating reactors control
rods were inserted into the reactor
cores to shut down self-sustained
fission and emergency generators were
switched on to power the cooling systems
this is an essential aspect of nuclear
safety because even after the control
rods stopped the self-sustaining fission
reaction the Reactor Core continues to
produce tremendous heat for many hours
because of continuing radioactive decay
thus it's critical to continue coolant
circulation for several days after a
shutdown
tragically at Fukushima 50 minutes after
the earthquake an earthquake induced
tsunami over top the plant's protective
sea wall and flooded the facility
causing the emergency generators to fail
the plants back up battery system
immediately took over but when the
batteries went dead the following day
there was nothing to prevent all three
reactor cores from melting down
in a meltdown the nuclear fuel elements
exceed their melting point causing
fission products to enter the coolant
water and greatly increasing the
possibility of a radioactive release
from the containment vessel at Fukushima
the result was a humanitarian
environmental and economic catastrophe
Fukushima effectively ended the nuclear
Renaissance while reminding the world
that despite stringent regulations
exacting engineering codes and extensive
redundant backup systems nuclear
accidents can still happen and when they
do the consequences can be dire indeed
beyond the potential for nuclear
accidents the long-term viability of
nuclear power is also plagued by the
still unresolved challenge of nuclear
waste disposal this challenge is
exacerbated by the high level of
radioactivity in the products of nuclear
fission
several of the new elements created when
uranium nuclei split apart have
half-lives of over a million years
these serious challenges notwithstanding
nuclear power is not going away anytime
soon in 2012 the U.S nuclear Regulatory
Commission approved the construction of
four new reactors at existing power
plants China India and South Korea are
building new reactors as well France
currently generates 75 percent of its
power with nuclear fission and even in
places where nuclear power has fallen
out of favor the immense capital
investment in existing plants provides a
strong incentive to keep them in
operation for as long as possible
but the very obvious question remains
can nuclear fusion be not only initiated
but controlled
could we somehow tap this incredibly
powerful reaction the way that Fermi did
with fission
it's a tantalizing Prospect just imagine
if we could tap nuclear fusion in a
controlled way
not using fission bombs to initiate
Fusion reactions that are over in less
than a second but more elegantly
conducted reaction
one in which hydrogen Isotopes are fused
into helium and the energy of that
process is tapped
we would have power plants that use the
most abundant element in the universe as
fuel and produce harmless stable helium
as waste that simply floats into space
but the problem that we run into is that
even deuterium tritium Fusion which is
the easiest type of fusion reaction to
start requires temperatures about 40
million kelvins to sustain
The energy needed to overcome the
columbic repulsion of the two hydrogen
nuclei is just so monstrous that we
can't run Fusion in a power plant the
way that we can do it in a bomb
there must be something fundamentally
different about how a fusion reactor is
designed if it's going to be practical
for power generation
we have to find a way to run the same
nuclear fusion reaction at drastically
lower temperatures
we have to create a type of cold fusion
a quest for controlled nuclear fusion
started about the same time that the
thermonuclear weapon or h-bomb research
began
attempts to use magnetic fields to
create containment systems capable of
generating High pressures have been
employed and physicists call this the
pinch technique
although many of these types of systems
have been able to contain high energy
hydrogen Isotopes none can create the
conditions right for nuclear fusion
perhaps the most well-known story of
controlled nuclear fusion is the
so-called Fleischmann pons experiment in
1989.
this experiment was a roller coaster
ride of emotion for researchers in the
field as it raised the world's hopes for
clean cheap fusion power just before
dashing those hopes nearly permanently
in 1989 Martin Fleischmann and Stanley
ponds were conducting electrochemical
research at the University of Utah
and they believe they were onto
something they had constructed a very
simple device that both men believe
would change the world
in ponds created an electrochemical half
cell using a platinum electrode
submersed in what is known as heavy
water or water containing deuterium
instead of hydrogen
of course the product of this half
reaction is deuterium itself which
should effervescent bubble out of the
system as hydrogen gas
but Fleischmann and pons had detected
deuterium in the Platinum electrode
itself
not a particularly surprising claim
since hydrogen gas interacts with
Platinum very strongly adhering to its
surface
but what they claimed next started a
storm of scientific controversy that's
the stuff of Legend
the two published a paper claiming that
they had detected heat in excess of any
expected chemical reaction that would go
on in their setup
in one of the most famous rushes to
press in all of scientific history
Fleischmann and ponds let their
excitement and the pressure to patent
their potentially world-changing
development hurry the publication of
their research
not long after their publication
scientists around the world began trying
to duplicate their results
there was just one problem
no one could
clearly Fleischmann pawns had been wrong
the resulting Fallout in the
professional and popular media was Swift
and intense
many popular magazines and newspapers
decry the entire situation as a debacle
and both public and institutional
support for the concept of cold fusion
was crushed
so the work of Fleischman and pons is
now taught not as an example of nearly
making the greatest discovery in the
history of mankind
but instead is a cautionary tale of what
is known as pathological science
the term used to describe a situation in
which a scientist originally working in
good faith using the scientific method
abandons objectivity and gives into what
is known as confirmation bias
to this very day Fusion research is
limited in part due to the bitter taste
left in all our mouths after the
infamous experiment in 1989.
but that doesn't mean that humankind
will never find a way to harness this
awesome reaction it simply means that we
may have to wait a generation or two
longer who knows
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
now on wandrium